au rayon boucherie on ne parlait que de
ça de la viande de boeuf frauduleuses
arrivé dans le loiret de quoi agacer ce
consommateur
c'est très grave c'est très très grave
parce que là franchement les gens déjà
il ya l'histoire des weygand ça va pas
arranger les choses non plus et il y en
a quand même un pays comme la france
avec toute la viande que l'on a pour les
bouchers écoeuré aussi cette nouvelle
affaire est l'occasion de rappeler
certaines pratiques
je pense qu'un directement les personnes
ont besoin de savoir la traçabilité de
la viande ça permet de faire une petite
piqûre de rappel en même temps nous ont
embauché de se différencier par rapport
à la con distribution et à autre lorsque
nous achetons nos bêtes sur pied donc on
est loin de ce problème
sur les 800 kg de viande frauduleuse
arrivée en france 19 kg ont été
formellement identifiés dans le loiret
par les services de la direction de la
protection des populations dans le
loiret ce que nous savons c'est qu'une
entreprise a reçu un peu moins de 20
kilos de cette viande et la
commercialiser ensuite mais en dehors du
département à l'étranger et donc il
appartient cette entreprise-là de
contacter ses clients pour leur demander
de retirer de la consommation celle de
l'entreprise concernée est un grossiste
du loiret identifiés par les services de
l'état
selon la préfecture la viande n'a donc
pas été commercialisée dans des
restaurants ou des boucheries du loiret
mais les professionnels sont confrontés
à l'inquiétude des clients
une personne qui a jeté hier du steak
haché et qui nous a demandé si ça
pouvait faire partie d'un lot a varié
donc je lui ai conforter donc lui dire
que non nous ça n'était pas possible que
ça rentre chez nous cette viande parce
que la chaîne monde peut acheter on
n'achète pas ces genres de la viande
frauduleuse arrivée dans le loiret est
donc reparti à l'étranger de quoi
laisser perplexe professionnels et
consommateurs